that if possible they should talk to a
doctor but the truth of the matter is
that everyone should feel comfortable
talking to a doctor about their own
bodies and that's why I think it's
really important for us to start this
dialogue about gross stuff from a pretty
early age so we can let our kids know
that it's all right to have agency over
your own body and over your own health
there's another reason that talking to
your doctor about your health and gross
stuff is really really important doctors
and the scientific community can only
address issues when they know there's
something to address so one of the
really interesting things I learned
while making the video on periods that I
was talking to this one scientist who
told me there's actually still a lot we
don't know about about periods like
there's a lot of basic research that
still hasn't been done and in part
that's just because there weren't a lot
of scientists in the field who were
women to ask questions about it and it's
also not a topic that women talk about
publicly so there's this gap in what we
know just because no one was there to
ask a question there's one final reason
that I think talking about gross Jeff is
so important and that's because you just
never know what you're gonna find when
you peel back all those layers of
disgustingness
so take the California brown sea hair
this is a sea slug that squirts this
lovely bright purple ink at any creature
that tries to eat it but it also happens
to be one of the kinkiest creatures in
the animal kingdom so these guys are
hermaphrodites which means they have
both male and female genitalia and when
it's time to mate up to 20 individuals
we'll all get together in this kind of
like conga line and they'll all mate
together a single fear will inseminate
the partner in front of it and receive
sperm from the one behind which is sort
of like an awesome time saver but if
scientists had only like saw this and
they were like okay we're just not going
to touch that with a stick they would
have missed the bigger thing about sea
hares that makes them really remarkable
so it turns out that these sea hares
have a small number of very large
neurons which makes them excellent to
use in neuroscience research and in fact
the scientist Eric Kandel used them in
his research to understand how memories
are stored and you know what he won a
Nobel Prize for his work so go out there
and pick up beetles and play in dirt and
ask questions and own your fascination
with gross stuff and don't be ashamed of
it because you never know what you're
gonna find and as I say at the end of
all my videos you know thank you
[Applause]